[موسيقى]
خطاب حماسي للجو بايدن امام حشد كبير من
البولنديين من جاره كييف وارسو اراد
الرئيس الامريكي اظهار وحده الغرب في
مواجهه روسيا مع اقتراب الذكرى الاولى
لغزوها اوكرانيا
لا ينبغي ان يكون هناك شك في ان دعمنا
لاوكرانيا لن يتراجع ولن ينقسم الناتو ولن
نتعب
[تصفيق]
شهوه الرئيس بوتين الجبانه للارض والسلطه
ستفشل وسينتصر حب شعب الاوكراني لبلده
في خطابه هاجمت جو بايدن فلاديمير بوتين
واعلن عن عقوبات مرتقبه جديده ضد روسيا في
الوقت ذاته رد على خطاب مناهض للغرب القاه
بالتزامن الرئيس الروسي
اتحدث مره اخرى الى شعب الروسي لا تسعى
الولايات المتحده والدول الاوروبيه الى
السيطره على روسيا او تدميرها والغرب لم
يتامر على مهاجمه روسيا كما قال بوتين
قبيل الخطاب اجتمع جو بايدن مع نظيره
البولندي
واشاد بدعم وارسولكييف من المقرر ان يجتمع
الرئيس الامريكي في وارسو مع حكومات تسع
دول من الجناح الشرقي لحلف شمال الاطلسي